[Music]
I left my friend said we escaped hear
those songs again
over me
things I've sacrificed
[Music]
you
[Music]
mr. steel
you still steal yes excuse me sir
sir is this yours
No
so where's dr. Anderson vacation
so mr. Steele what is it you do for a
living
financial transfers Mike thank you huh
something like that are you ready sure
open what for
he flows well you know the benevolent
bank at 1510 oh it's a huge place makes
the first world bank look like a toy
store I guess uh no needles I can handle
it
I have a friend a patient who works
there says that the vault is practically
impenetrable I wouldn't know
I say well your need is the right thrill
how about that no Kendrick huh
look Lex gonna do some good I wouldn't
know I'm not into politics no but mr.
steel I hate like the opposite or should
I call you Dallas you know we take pride
in taking good care of our patients but
when they don't floss it breaks poor
Olga's heart I guess I'll start today
good good so what'd he want it should be
obvious about enough I want you to work
for me
open I have to say I've been following
you and your crew for some time now
it's quite impressive what you did with
the election with such poor planning I
have no idea what you're talking about
of course not
then I guess you don't want to know what
I have planned for you do I have a
choice
when things cool down after the
benevolent bank I'd like to send you on
a little road trip to the National
Gallery the diamond
not just any diamond ddiamond
Dax James gang tried to pull that off
last year they all ended up in jail
except for Dexter himself bite down on
this did they bite his body some of it
the rightful owner another patient of
mine will celebrate by sending you and
your boys to Las Vegas sorry I don't
gamble
the golden grin casino has more to offer
than just craps and cards preplanning
how's the tooth it's good I'm glad to
hear that
we done here sure excuse me very
entertaining listening to your schemes I
have another one oh I'm sure you do how
did it feel
leaving him behind Olga would you show
mr. Steele the Department of Corrections
transfer plan for inmate Jim Hawksworth
when do we start right now
you see I need my payday to
[Music]
[Music]